Avant que la vidéo ne commence, j’ai une
question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
________________
PREMIÈRE RÉFÉRENCE
Romans de la Table ronde (fin XIIe siècle),
Chrétien de Troyes
Les cinéastes américains — et amis — George
Lucas et Steven Spielberg se sont inspirés
de Lancelot, un personnage des Romans de la
Table ronde de Chrétien de Troyes, pour créer
le personnage d’Indiana Jones dans les années
1980. Tout comme le chevalier de la littérature
française du XIIe siècle, l’archéologue
américain se lance dans diverses aventures
pour récupérer des artefacts anciens. Et
ses péripéties se déroulent dans une atmosphère
mythologique qui rappelle celle des récits
de Chrétien de Troyes.
Cette atmosphère mythologique est plus précisément
celle des « légendes arthuriennes ». On
qualifie ces légendes d’« arthuriennes
» parce qu’elles sont centrées sur la
légende du roi Arthur, un seigneur breton
qui aurait résisté aux barbares au milieu
du Ier millénaire. Les chevaliers de ce roi
s’appelaient les « chevaliers de la table
ronde », c’est pourquoi leurs histoires
s’appellent les « romans de la table ronde
». Ils étaient notamment en quête du Graal,
un objet mythique dont la possession permettrait
de rétablir la paix dans le royaume.
Qu’on retrouve l’influence de ces légendes
dans les super-productions américaines de
la fin du XXe siècle révèle bien l’importance
des Romans de la table ronde de Chrétien
de Troyes dans la culture populaire occidentale.
Qu’en dire sur le plan de la forme ?
Ces romans ont été écrits en ancien français
(la première langue française, en usage
du IXe au XIIIe siècle, et qui dérivait
du latin parlé) — mais ils sont aujourd’hui
disponibles dans des traductions modernes
très digestes qui préservent l’identité
du style initial.
Chrétien de Troyes écrit en vers octosyllabiques
(donc huit syllabes), la forme poétique typique
de la littérature médiévale française.
Son style est poétique, c’est-à-dire qu’il
produit de belles images. D’un côté, la
richesse des descriptions et les références
culturelles datées rebutent des lecteurs
modernes comme nous ; mais de l’autre côté,
nous apprécions encore la finesse psychologique
avec laquelle Chrétien de Troyes présente
ses personnages. Et puis le ton de la narration
est souvent ironique et humoristique. Enfin,
la structure narrative est assez complexe
(notamment, Chrétien de Troyes enchâsse
les récits).
Je vous résume très rapidement ses 3 plus
importants romans :
1. Yvain, ou le Chevalier au lion raconte
l’histoire d’Yvain, chevalier à la cour
du roi Arthur, qui va d'aventure en aventure
(où il prend la défense des faibles) avec
un lion (qu'il a sauvé) afin de convaincre
son épouse de le reprendre. On retrouve donc
le thème de la vertu ennoblissante de l’amour
: Yvain se dépasse par des actions d’une
grande noblesse pour (re)séduire sa femme.
Vous avez peut-être étudié cette histoire
si vous avez fait votre scolarité dans un
collège français.
2. Lancelot, ou le Chevalier de la charrette
raconte l’histoire de chevaliers de la cour
du roi Arthur qui enchaînent les aventures
pour ramener la reine Guenièvre, enlevée
par un mystérieux étranger. Une idée importante
de ce roman, c’est qu'il faut accepter l'humiliation
par amour, car Lancelot accepte de circuler
sur une charrette (comme un manant, c’est-à-dire
un homme de basse condition) plutôt que sur
un cheval. C’est encore un classique des
cours de français au collège.
3. Conte du Graal, ou le Roman de Perceval
(inachevé) raconte l’histoire de Perceval,
qui devient chevalier contre la volonté de
sa mère (dont le mari et les autres fils
étaient déjà morts au combat). Ses prouesses
de chevalier le font inviter par un roi misérable.
Au château, il assiste à un étrange spectacle
: une procession où l'on porte un grand vase
— le Graal — et une lance qui saigne.
Ce n’est qu’après des années de pérégrinations
qu’il peut assister de nouveau à la procession
et poser les questions qui rendraient la prospérité
au pays. Au début du XIIIe siècle, une grande
tradition romanesque se centrera autour du
Graal (qui deviendra même un accessoire de
Jésus-Christ), et des auteurs réécriront
l'histoire de Lancelot. On retrouvera encore
le Graal dans les aventures d’Indiana Jones.
Les Romans de la table ronde de Chrétien
de Troyes sont très importants dans la littérature
française parce qu’ils symbolisent la naissance
de la forme littéraire du « roman ».
Qu’est-ce qu’un roman ?
À l’origine, c’est simplement une traduction
d'un ouvrage du latin en langue romane (d’où
le nom de « roman »). Le mot désigne donc
d’abord toute production littéraire en
langue romane. Mais ces productions racontent
souvent le même type d’histoires, donc
la définition de ce qu’est un roman se
précise au XIIe siècle : un roman désigne
désormais un récit d'aventures en français,
où l'amour tient une large place.
Les Romans de la table ronde de Chrétien
de Troyes sont donc aussi importants sur le
fond. Par leurs thèmes, ils lancent ce qu’on
appelle la « littérature courtoise ». Les
deux ingrédients de cette littérature, ce
sont la chevalerie et l’amour dit « courtois
» (l’amour courtois, c’est l’idéal
amoureux né dans les cours [d’où l’adjectif
« courtois »] du Moyen Âge, et cet idéal
prescrit que l’homme adore en souffrant
une femme inaccessible).
Plein d’autres auteurs du Moyen Âge inventeront
des histoires sur le même modèle : un chevalier
errant solitaire qui s'engage dans une série
d'épreuves pour prouver sa valeur, effacer
une faute (souvent vis-à-vis d'une femme)
ou conjurer un sortilège.
La dimension psychologique du parcours du
personnage dans ce modèle de récit (en fait,
le personnage est en quête de la maturité)
— cette dimension psychologique est à l’origine
de la tradition européenne dite du « roman
d'apprentissage », ou Bildungsroman en allemand
(les Illusions perdues de Balzac ou L’Éducation
sentimentale de Flaubert seront de fameux
exemples de cette tradition au XIXe siècle
en France).
On retrouvera plus globalement les thèmes
des Romans de la table ronde dans certains
des chefs-d’œuvre de la littérature française.
Par exemple, Rabelais fera une satire des
codes de la chevalerie dans Gargantua en décrivant
des combats absurdes et excessifs, tout en
donnant à son protagoniste la noblesse d’âme
qu’on attend de l’idéal chevaleresque.
________________
DEUXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Gargantua (1534), François Rabelais
En 1564, l'Église catholique inscrit Gargantua
de Rabelais à l’Index librorum prohibitorum
(en français « Index des livres interdits
»). Le langage du roman est jugé obscène
par les autorités religieuses ; son contenu
est jugé scandaleux. Mais cela n’empêche
pas les éditeurs d’imprimer de nombreuses
éditions qui circulent dans toute l’Europe.
Ce roman inspirera des générations d’auteurs
français jusqu’au XXe siècle, où les
autorités l’inscrivent à une autre liste
: celle des classiques de la littérature
française.
Le nom « Gargantua » est même passé dans
la langue française : il a donné l’adjectif
« gargantuesque », qui signifie « démesuré
» (la plupart du temps en parlant de la quantité
de nourriture [on peut par exemple dire qu’un
repas a été « gargantuesque »]).
Sur le plan du style, Rabelais est à la fois
grossier et inventif. Il crée des jeux de
mots et des expressions comiques en jouant
avec la langue française. Il est l’auteur
de nombreux néologismes. Par exemple, il
invente le mot « automate » pour désigner
de petits engins qui se déplacent de manière
autonome. Autre exemple intéressant, il donne
un nouveau sens au mot « quintessence », qui
désignait autrefois l’essence du ciel (qui
est la cinquième essence après les 4 éléments
que sont la terre, l’air, l’eau et le
feu) : mais Rabelais, lui, emploie le mot
« quintessence » pour désigner ce qu’il
y a de plus important et de meilleur dans
une chose (« tirer la quintessence d’un
livre », par exemple).
Le langage et la structure narrative rendent
Gargantua difficile à lire pour un francophone
du XXIe siècle — mais on peut toujours
goûter l’humour et l’inventivité de
Rabelais.
Gargantua est ce qu’on appelle aujourd’hui
un « préquel ». En effet, Rabelais a d’abord
écrit Pantagruel, le roman qui, comme son
titre l’indique, raconte les aventures de
Pantagruel, le fils du géant Gargantua. Pantagruel
a connu un succès immédiat, ce qui a incité
Rabelais à écrire sur le père.
Le roman débute avec la naissance extraordinaire
de Gargantua. Fils d’un roi, il naît de
l'oreille de sa mère en demandant immédiatement
à boire, ce qui lui vaut son nom (Gargantua
signifie en effet « quel gosier ["gargante"
en langue d’oc] tu as »). Au cours de son
enfance, son père, persuadé de sa grande
intelligence, lui attribue un précepteur
qui l'éduque de manière archaïque. Plus
tard, le père décide d'envoyer Gargantua
étudier à Paris, où il fait les 400 coups
(il vole notamment les cloches de Notre-Dame,
ce qui parodie les exploits chevaleresques).
Finalement, il rejoint son précepteur, qui
constatant ses mauvaises manières, entreprend
de le remettre sur le droit chemin des écritures
saintes. Gargantua acquiert alors de nombreux
savoirs intellectuels. Pendant ce temps, son
père entre en guerre contre un autre roi,
et demande l'aide de son fils. S'ensuivent
de nombreux combats et victoires.
Les années d’apprentissage et les exploits
guerriers de Gargantua servent de prétexte
à un plaidoyer pour une éducation humaniste
fondée sur la curiosité intellectuelle.
La morale libérale de l’histoire est contenue
dans la devise de l'abbaye utopique imaginée
à la fin du roman, l’abbaye de Thélème
: « Fais ce que tu voudras ».
Pourquoi ce roman est-il si important dans
la littérature française ?
Tout d’abord, il est emblématique du genre
dit « picaresque ». L’adjectif « picaresque
» vient de l’espagnol pícaro, qui signifie
« coquin ». Le roman picaresque est donc
importé de la littérature espagnole, et
il raconte les aventures d'un personnage de
basse extraction, le Picaro, un mauvais garçon
qui n'a pour lui que sa débrouillardise.
Ensuite, Gargantua a également marqué la
littérature française par son plaidoyer
pour une éducation humaniste (je précise
que l’humanisme est le courant culturel
de la Renaissance qui veut relever la dignité
de l'esprit humain en reliant la culture moderne
à la culture antique). Dans le récit, l’éducation
médiévale classique que reçoit Gargantua
est abrutissante et ne le prépare pas aux
défis de la vie réelle. L’éducation alternative
dessinée par Rabelais repose sur la curiosité,
et non pas sur la tradition et l'autorité
intellectuelle. Cet idéal inspirera notamment
les auteurs des Lumières.
Plus profondément, enfin, le roman illustre
le message général de Rabelais. Il invite
l’homme à vivre librement et avec réalisme.
Il faut prendre en charge sa propre destinée,
plutôt que de s’en remettre aux religions.
En particulier, il ne faut pas écouter les
partisans de la mythologie de l'amour-passion
qui dévalorisent la vie matérielle. Il est
légitime d'aimer le monde et de tirer des
joies du passage sur terre. Rabelais souligne
aussi plus précisément un risque de l’identité
artistique de la Renaissance : il ne faut
pas que l'inféodation aux Anciens remplace
l'inféodation à l'Église.
En faisant une apologie de la liberté intellectuelle
sous une forme audacieuse, Rabelais écrit
un roman qui sera longtemps un des plus populaires
de la littérature française. Il la marque
de son empreinte à la fois sur la forme et
sur le fond, en enrichissant la langue française
et en ouvrant la voie à la satire sociale
et politique (on peut dire à cet égard que
Molière sera le plus célèbre héritier
de Rabelais).
________________
TROISIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
La Princesse de Clèves (1678), Madame de
La Fayette
Début 2006, Nicolas Sarkozy, alors ministre
de l'intérieur et candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle, promet devant une
assemblée de fonctionnaires d'« en finir
avec la pression des concours et des examens
». Et il illustre cette promesse en racontant
qu’il a vu que le programme du concours
d'attaché d'administration prévoit d'interroger
les candidats sur La Princesse de Clèves
de Madame de La Fayette. À ses yeux, il est
parfaitement inutile qu’un fonctionnaire
soit capable de parler de cette œuvre.
Sa remarque fait un tollé chez les enseignants,
les artistes et les intellectuels, qui y voient
le projet d’enterrer la culture littéraire.
En revanche, les éditeurs ne sont pas mécontents.
Le livre redevient un best-seller dans les
trois années suivant la déclaration du ministre
de l’intérieur, au point de parler d’un
« effet Sarkozy ». La Princesse de Clèves
a toujours été un classique de la littérature
française — mais son nom est désormais
attaché à une polémique politique récente,
d’où son regain de notoriété.
Maintenant, quoi retenir à propos du roman
lui-même ?
Sur la forme, le style de Madame de La Fayette
est emblématique du classicisme français,
qui valorise la clarté et la rigueur de l'expression
(le philosophe Pascal, qui est un des plus
grands représentants de ce style, disait
« l’éloquence se passe de l’éloquence
» — autrement dit, il faut faire simple).
Conformément à cet idéal de sobriété,
Madame de La Fayette décrit les émotions,
les pensées et les actions des personnages
avec un langage épuré, en évitant les ornements
inutiles. Elle reste à distance de l’histoire
en la racontant à la troisième personne
avec une narration omnisciente et en mettant
à profit la forme passive, qui donne un caractère
impersonnel à ses descriptions.
Petite anecdote intéressante : Madame de
La Fayette ne signait pas ses œuvres de son
vivant, parce qu’elle ne voulait pas laisser
croire qu'elle avait besoin de vendre des
livres pour vivre.
Je vous résume rapidement l’histoire, qui
se passe sous le règne du roi de France Henri
II (au XVIe siècle, Madame de La Fayette
étant, elle, une femme de lettres du siècle
suivant).
L’héroïne, Mademoiselle de Chartres, est
une jeune femme d’une grande beauté, élevée
dans la vertu. Après être entrée à la
cour du roi Henri II, elle épouse le Prince
de Clèves (et devient donc la Princesse de
Clèves). Cet homme d’âge mûr est épris
d’elle, mais ce n’est pas réciproque.
Elle estime son mari sans avoir de sentiments
pour lui.
C’est un autre homme qui va lui inspirer
des sentiments : le duc de Nemours, qu’elle
rencontre lors d’un bal. Là, la passion
est réciproque. Ils s’aiment violemment.
Le duc de Nemours veut vivre cette passion,
mais la Princesse de Clèves veut rester digne
de l’engagement qu’elle a pris auprès
de son mari. Donc elle se retire de la cour
et en avoue la raison à son vieux mari, ce
qui le fait mourir de jalousie (il ne souffre
pas seulement, il meurt vraiment). Alors qu’elle
pourrait vivre son amour avec le duc de Nemours,
la Princesse de Clèves se retire dans un
couvent jusqu’à la fin de ses jours.
Ce scénario illustre un débat des salons
galants de l’époque : « Comment une femme
mariée doit-elle réagir si un homme lui
confie son amour ? ».
La Princesse de Clèves est un des plus grands
romans français pour plusieurs raisons.
La première, c’est l’innovation que représente
l’approche psychologique de Madame de La
Fayette. Plutôt que de privilégier l’intrigue
et l’action, elle entre dans la tête des
personnages pour décrire leurs pensées et
leurs motivations. Elle a donc écrit un des
premiers « romans psychologiques » de la
littérature française.
Ensuite, ce roman a un intérêt historique
: c’est un témoignage sur les relations
humaines à la cour du roi de France au XVIe
siècle.
Une autre raison de l’importance du roman,
c’est que Madame de La Fayette parle d’amour
d’une manière à la fois originale et subtile,
avec pour toile de fond la tension entre la
passion et la vertu. La victoire finale de
la vertu illustre la nécessité de se tenir
à l’écart des plaisirs du monde. C’était
un des grands thèmes du jansénisme, la nouvelle
version du catholicisme qui se développe
sous Louis XIV, et qui inspire de grands auteurs
comme Pascal.
Enfin, La Princesse de Clèves deviendra aussi
une référence de la littérature française
en tant que modèle de l’excellence (sur
le plan du style) de la prose classique.
En plus de l’approche psychologique et historique,
ce roman stimulera la littérature féminine
(c’est un roman écrit par une femme pour
un public féminin) ; et il stimulera également
la forme de la nouvelle (La Princesse de Clèves
est divisé en courts chapitres, et puis la
narration a le souci de la vraisemblance qui
caractérise le genre de la nouvelle).
________________
QUATRIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Les Liaisons dangereuses (1782), Pierre Choderlos
de Laclos
En 1959, le réalisateur français Roger Vadim
réalise la première adaptation de ce roman.
Seulement, le tout neuf ministère des Affaires
culturelles confié par le général de Gaulle
à André Malraux et certaines autorités
locales jugent que le film viole les normes
de décence de l'époque. Il est donc en partie
censuré. Ce livre qui avait créé le scandale
à la veille de la Révolution française
continue donc de menacer la morale sociale
près de 200 ans plus tard.
Les Liaisons dangereuses passe pour le dernier
grand roman épistolaire. Laclos réussit
à donner une impression de spontanéité
et d'authenticité aux lettres échangées
entre les personnages. Son style est clair,
précis et concis. En même temps, il réussit
bien à exprimer la complexité de la psychologie
des personnages. Leurs lettres sont souvent
remplies de sous-entendus qui créent une
atmosphère de duplicité. Elles expriment,
grâce à la plume de l’auteur, un mélange
subtil d’ambition et de vulnérabilité.
Laclos affecte même à chacun de ses personnages
un style qui permet au lecteur, dès les quelques
premières phrases de chaque lettre, de reconnaître
la patte de celui ou celle qui l'écrit.
Pour quelqu’un qui n’a jamais eu affaire
au français du XVIIIe siècle, la prose de
Laclos ne sera pas forcément une partie de
plaisir. Mais si vous n’êtes pas dans ce
cas, ce roman sera probablement une lecture
agréable.
Je vous en résume le fond rapidement.
Il est composé de 175 lettres d’un duo
machiavélique d’aristocrates. Valmont,
un homme fortuné et oisif, passe son temps
à séduire les femmes. Il complote avec la
marquise de Merteuil pour corrompre une jeune
fille, Cécile, ainsi qu'une honnête femme,
Mme de Tourvel. Cette intrigue sert à critiquer
le libertinage (les deux comploteurs finissent
mal). L’argument de Laclos est que l'idéal
libertin ne consiste pas à prendre du plaisir
avec autrui, mais à dominer et corrompre.
Seulement, le succès du livre est dû à
la peinture qu'il fait du libertinage, c’est-à-dire
fondamentalement à la puissance d’attraction
de l’interdit. À sa parution, les gens
le lisent secrètement pour mieux s’offusquer
de son parfum de soufre et de ses allusions
sexuelles.
Avec le temps, Les Liaisons dangereuses symboliseront
dans l’histoire de la littérature française
le développement du roman libertin à l’époque
des Lumières (on peut aussi citer l’autobiographie
de Casanova et l’œuvre du marquis de Sade,
à propos duquel j’ai déjà fait une vidéo
sur cette chaîne). L’idéologie des Lumières
promeut le papillonnage sexuel, parce que
la logique du désir fait qu’il ne peut
pas rester intense sans changer d’objet.
Le roman passera également à la postérité
comme un modèle de critique sociale. En effet,
Laclos donne à voir l’hypocrisie de la
haute société française de son époque
ainsi que des relations hommes femmes. Enfin,
les lettres dévoilant la complexité de l’âme
humaine, certains voient dans Les Liaisons
dangereuses l’annonce du réalisme psychologique
dont feront preuve les romanciers du XIXe
siècle.
Ce roman aura une influence durable dans la
culture occidentale, comme le prouvent les
multiples adaptations dont il a fait l’objet
au cinéma. Celle réalisée en 1988 par le
réalisateur anglais Stephen Frears (avec
notamment John Malkovitch dans le rôle du
Vicomte de Valmont) — cette adaptation remportera
trois Oscars. Bien sûr, les producteurs misent
sur cette histoire pour bénéficier de la
puissance d’attraction du tabou de la sexualité.
Une adaptation de l’intrigue au monde adolescent
réalisée en 1999 a d’ailleurs un titre
très suggestif en français, Sexe intentions
(« Cruel Intentions » en anglais).
________________
CINQUIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Le Rouge et le Noir (1830), Stendhal
En 1954, le célèbre critique littéraire
britannique William Somerset Maugham (qui
avait grandi à Paris parmi l’élite culturelle
française) — ce critique britannique classe
Le Rouge et le Noir de Stendhal 3ème de son
top 10 des plus grands romans de tous les
temps (toutes nationalités confondues). Et
c’est aussi le premier roman français de
ce top 10.
Le Rouge et le Noir n’est donc pas seulement
incontournable dans la littérature française,
mais carrément dans le patrimoine littéraire
de l’humanité.
Le style de Stendhal ne fait pas l’unanimité
à son époque et dans la suite du XIXe siècle
— il a même la réputation d’écrire
mal. D’un côté, Balzac admire le caractère
à la fois clair et incisif de la prose de
Stendhal ; de l’autre côté, Flaubert en
critique la simplicité délibérée, qui
confine à la banalité.
En effet, contrairement aux modèles de son
époque (comme Chateaubriand), Stendhal refuse
le lyrisme et les effets de style. « Les
livres immortels, affirme-t-il, ont été
faits en pensant fort peu au style. » À
ses yeux, il ne faut pas tartiner, mais être
direct et miser sur l’implicite. Il estime
que l’élégance creuse des auteurs de son
temps les condamne à ne plus être lus par
les futures générations. « Je mets, dit-il,
un billet à la loterie dont le gros lot se
résume à ceci : être lu en 1935. » C’est
vrai que Stendhal est toujours lu — mais
il avait quand même sous-estimé l’exigence
de simplicité des lecteurs du XXIe siècle
(dont beaucoup se plaignent que Le Rouge et
le Noir est trop difficile à lire).
Enfin, le style de Stendhal s’explique aussi
par ses « conditions de production » (pour
parler un peu comme un marxiste). Ayant des
problèmes de vue, Stendhal dicte souvent
ses textes à des amis ou à des secrétaires.
Cette manière de faire favorise les phrases
courtes et directes, et donne par là à la
prose la spontanéité de l’oral.
Passons au fond maintenant.
Voici tout d’abord le sens du titre : Stendhal
ne l’a pas expliqué lui-même, mais l’explication
la plus courante est que le rouge est la couleur
des habits de l’armée, tandis que le noir
est la couleur des habits des prêtres. Dans
le roman, le héros hésite entre, d’une
part, un destin militaire (car il a une passion
pour Napoléon) ; et d’autre part l’institution
religieuse, qui a favorisé son ascension
sociale en lui permettant d’étudier.
Je vous résume rapidement l’intrigue, qui
est inspirée d’un fait divers.
Le protagoniste s’appelle Julien Sorel.
Fils d’un scieur d’un village de Franche-Comté,
il a du goût pour les idées et un potentiel
intellectuel, contrairement à son père artisan.
La première partie de l’histoire se passe
en Franche-Comté.
Julien est un jeune homme chétif de 19 ans.
Sa famille méprise son attrait pour les idées,
mais il bénéficie du soutien d’un abbé.
Cela lui permet d’être engagé par le maire
du village, M. de Rênal, comme précepteur
des enfants. Il vit alors une idylle avec
la femme de son employeur, Mme de Rênal,
et lorsque leur relation commence à éveiller
les soupçons, le maire le contraint à partir.
Envisageant une carrière dans l’Église,
Julien entre au séminaire de Besançon. Un
abbé y détecte son ambition de savoir et
l’envoie à Paris comme secrétaire du marquis
de la Mole.
La seconde partie de l’histoire se déroule
essentiellement à Paris.
Julien séduit la fille de son employeur,
Mathilde. Non seulement leur passion devient
notoire, mais la jeune femme tombe enceinte.
Le père hésite à accepter un mariage avec
un homme provincial. Il refuse finalement
après avoir reçu une lettre de Mme de Rênal
qui, sous l’influence de son confesseur,
dénonce l’ambition et l’immoralité de
son ancien amant. Julien se venge alors en
tirant deux coups de feu sur Mme de Rênal
(qui survit). Il est condamné à mort. Ses
deux anciennes amantes font tout pour le sauver
— en vain.
Le Rouge et le Noir renouvelle le roman français
à plusieurs titres.
C’est tout d’abord un modèle de roman
d’apprentissage (comme on en trouve d’autres
au XIXe siècle), c’est-à-dire que l’histoire
nous fait suivre la maturation psychologique
du héros. Julien Sorel est un provincial
ambitieux qui, animé par une énergie napoléonienne,
conquiert le savoir, les femmes, et la haute
société.
Ensuite, Le Rouge et le Noir est un modèle
de réalisme. Stendhal s’appuie sur un fait
divers et écrit une histoire crédible. Émile
Zola, le chef de file du naturalisme (la doctrine
esthétique qui proscrit toute idéalisation
de la réalité) — Zola estimera en fait
que Stendhal est le véritable père du courant.
« Un roman, écrit Stendhal dans Le Rouge
et le Noir, est un miroir qui se promène
sur une grande route. »
Enfin, Le Rouge et le Noir est encore un modèle
de roman psychologique parce que Stendhal
analyse en profondeur ce qui se passe dans
l’esprit des personnages, tout particulièrement
dans celui du héros. Il capture l’essence
des émotions humaines. Au tournant du XXe
siècle, Paul Bourget et André Gide estimeront
même — en exagérant — que Stendhal est
l’inventeur de la nouvelle psychologique.
Nietzsche, quant à lui, dira que Stendhal
est « le dernier des grands psychologues
français ».
________________
SIXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Le Père Goriot (1835), Honoré de Balzac
Pour vous parler du Rouge et le Noir de Stendhal,
j’ai commencé par vous dire qu’il était
classé 3ème du top 10 des plus grands romans
de tous les temps du critique littéraire
britannique William Somerset Maugham — eh
bien Le Père Goriot de Balzac est juste derrière,
4ème de ce classement.
Et ce chef-d’œuvre a été écrit en seulement
40 jours ! À en croire la biographie de Balzac
de Stefan Zweig, les cafés bien forts et
la pression des huissiers permettaient au
romancier français de rester assis 16 heures
par jour. Personnellement, j’ai un petit
doute sur la véracité de cette anecdote
— mais le résultat est là : Le Père Goriot
a été produit très rapidement.
Que retenir concernant la forme de ce roman
?
La prose n’a pas la simplicité de celle
de Stendhal. On retrouve les ingrédients
clés du style de Balzac, les phrases longues
et les descriptions abondantes. Si ces descriptions
créent un univers complet et riche de détails,
elles surchargent parfois le texte et peuvent
décourager des lecteurs peu expérimentés
ou peu patients. La poésie du style de Balzac
a la même ambivalence : d’un côté, il
crée de belles images, parfois magnifiques
; de l’autre côté, l’effort d’éloquence
alourdit le style.
Balzac, qui vendait beaucoup de livres, se
la pétait en disant « Il n’y a à Paris
que trois hommes qui sachent écrire, Hugo,
Gautier et moi. » — mais ce n’est pas
son style qui l’a fait passer à la postérité.
Même les critiques lui reprochent sa tendance
à tartiner (qui lui vient certainement de
ses débuts comme ghostwriter), ainsi que
sa tendance à la généralisation hâtive
(qui lui vient certainement de son goût pour
la philosophie).
Que retenir concernant le fond, maintenant
?
C’est l'histoire d'un père, Goriot (d’où
le titre du roman), qui a sacrifié toute
sa fortune pour ses deux filles, Anastasie
et Delphine. Ces deux femmes sont mariées
à des hommes riches, mais elles ne s'intéressent
qu'à leur propre plaisir, réduisant leur
père à la pauvreté. Eugène de Rastignac,
un jeune homme ambitieux de la province, arrive
à Paris pour poursuivre ses études de droit
(le nom propre « Rastignac » deviendra un
nom commun qui désigne une personne qui veut
réussir à tout prix). Rastignac fait la
connaissance du père Goriot et découvre
l'histoire de ses filles. Il rencontre Vautrin,
un homme manipulateur, qui lui propose de
tuer le mari d'Anastasie pour qu'elle puisse
se remarier avec un homme plus riche. Eugène
est horrifié et refuse. Le père Goriot meurt
abandonné de ses filles et Eugène est tiraillé
entre son amour pour Delphine et sa conscience
morale.
Bref, Balzac dépeint l'ambition et la corruption
de la société française du début du XIXe
siècle à travers le destin de Rastignac,
qui fait son apprentissage de la vie, de la
société et des hommes (on retrouve donc
la dimension du roman d’apprentissage).
Paris, en particulier, apparaît comme une
ville livrée au plaisir, où les honnêtes
gens se déchirent entre eux.
C’est donc le fond — et non pas la forme
— de ce roman qui en fait un chef-d’œuvre.
Il s’inscrit dans le courant réaliste dans
la mesure où il peint la réalité dans ce
qu’elle a de plus varié, mais aussi de
plus sordide. Balzac dévoile l’immoralité
de la société parisienne de son époque
à travers des personnages complexes et crédibles.
Abandonné par ses filles dans la vieillesse
et la pauvreté, le père Goriot symbolise
la cruauté dont sont capables les individus
corrompus par l’émulation de la vie dans
la capitale.
Balzac montre plus profondément le rôle
primordial de l’argent dans les rapports
humains. « Dis-moi ce que tu as, disait-il,
je te dirai ce que tu penses. » Il enseigne
par la fiction la grande leçon du marxisme,
puis de l’existentialisme : la mentalité
d’un homme, ses préférences et ses valeurs,
découlent de ses conditions d’existence.
Bref, c’est le milieu qui fait l’homme.
C’est pour cette raison qu’on dira que
Balzac est un sociologue, ou que certains
diront, plus spécifiquement, que « tout
Marx est dans Balzac » (d’ailleurs Marx
aimait les romans de Balzac).
________________
SEPTIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Le Comte de Monte-Cristo, Alexandre Dumas
La ville de Marseille organise chaque année,
depuis 1999, une traversée à la nage entre
le château d’If et la plage du Roucas-Blanc
(au sud de la ville). Et il y a jusqu’à
plusieurs milliers de participants (même
si une partie se contentent d’un parcours
moins long). Cette traversée commémore pourtant
un évènement fictif… l’évasion de prison
du héros du roman d’Alexandre Dumas.
Dans sa version intégrale, ce roman fait
près de 2000 pages.
Le style de Dumas est vif et fluide, ce qui
convient bien à une histoire d’aventure.
Les dialogues sont vivants. La narration est
omnisciente, ce qui permet de transporter
le lecteur d’une situation à la suivante
et d’un personnage au suivant (et il y en
a beaucoup). La prose de Dumas est globalement
plutôt romantique dans la mesure où il décrit
les lieux, les émotions et les sentiments
des personnages.
Mais ce qui est exceptionnel, c’est la maîtrise
technique avec laquelle le romancier réussit
à conserver l’attention du lecteur du début
à la fin. La construction de l’intrigue
et des personnages est redoutablement efficace.
Le Comte de Monte-Cristo est un récit intemporel
et universel qui est encore ce qu’on appelle
un « page-turner » au XXIe siècle.
Quelle en est l’histoire ?
Le roman raconte le destin d’Edmond Dantès,
un jeune marin de 19 ans.
Cela commence en 1815, au début du règne
de Louis XVIII, alors que Napoléon se prépare
à quitter l'île d'Elbe (où il était en
exil après son abdication). Le jeune héros,
Edmond Dantès, débarque à Marseille pour
s'y fiancer le lendemain avec la belle Catalane
Mercédès.
Mais voilà, son bonheur fait des jaloux,
qui ourdissent un complot contre lui. Il est
dénoncé comme conspirateur bonapartiste
et enfermé dans une geôle du château d'If,
au large de Marseille. Il y passera 14 ans.
Il souffre d’abord de la solitude, qui le
plonge dans le désespoir. Puis il en sort
grâce à son compagnon de captivité, l'abbé
Faria. Cet abbé transforme Edmond Dantès
: il lui apprend tout ce qu’il sait, son
savoir et sa maîtrise des langues ; il le
soutient dans son projet d’évasion ; et
avant de mourir il lui signale l’existence
d’un trésor caché dans l'île de Montecristo.
C’est comme ça qu’Edmond Dantès devient
le comte de Monte-Cristo.
Désormais riche, Dantès revient dans le
monde sous divers noms d’emprunt, notamment
celui du compte de Monte-Cristo. Il entreprend
de garantir le bonheur et la liberté aux
rares personnes qui lui sont restés fidèles.
En revanche, il se venge méthodiquement de
ceux qui sont responsables de son emprisonnement.
Pour faire simple, Le Comte de Monte-Cristo
est un des plus grands romans d'aventure jamais
écrits. Il a popularisé le genre en France
et il a inspiré de nombreux auteurs, cinéastes
et artistes dans le monde entier. Il a été
adapté une dizaine de fois à l’écran
depuis les années 1950 (le héros a notamment
été incarné par Gérard Depardieu dans
un feuilleton réalisé en 1998).
Ce roman est aussi plus précisément devenu
la référence de la littérature française
sur le thème de la vengeance. Comme les grands
hommes décrits par Hegel dans La raison dans
l’histoire, Edmond Dantès est habité par
une mission qui lui donne une volonté surhumaine.
Il est extrêmement pâle ; il voit dans le
noir ; et il ne mange pas.
Le pouvoir de fascination de ce personnage
dépasse la sphère de la littérature : le
comte de Monte-Cristo est devenu une icône
culturelle, presque un archétype de l’imaginaire
collectif occidental. Il a inspiré et il
inspire encore des générations de jeunes
ambitieux parce qu’il représente, pour
eux, la vengeance par le succès sur les personnes
qui n’ont pas cru en eux. On reconnaît
aussi dans le destin d’Edmond Dantès le
parcours mythique du héros : il disparaît
du monde pendant un certain temps ; il surmonte
des obstacles ; puis il revient transformé,
parvenu à la maturité psychologique.
________________
Petite interruption parce que je me dis que
si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
________________
HUITIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Madame Bovary, Gustave Flaubert
Ce roman serait le préféré de Brigitte
Macron comme d’Emmanuel Macron.
Le président y a d’ailleurs fait une référence
lors d’une interview à TF1 de mars 2017,
soit un mois avant l’élection présidentielle.
Alors candidat, il repousse une question de
la journaliste en évoquant un « bovarysme
journalistique » qu’il définit comme la
tendance à se focaliser sur les étapes suivantes
au lieu de parler des affaires du moment.
Cette expression inspirée par le roman de
Flaubert fait référence à la propension
de l’héroïne à s’échapper de la réalité
présente en se projetant dans ses fantasmes.
Que dire de la forme de ce roman ?
On retrouve le souci de la perfection de Flaubert,
qui polit chaque phrase dans le détail par
un travail acharné de retouche. Il a travaillé
à ce roman pendant 5 ans, en testant la cadence
et l’harmonie du texte au gueuloir. On le
surnomme « Monsieur un mot par jour » parce
qu’il écrit très lentement.
Son vocabulaire riche et précis (plutôt
que vague et abstrait) décrit les personnages
et les scènes de manière détaillée. Flaubert
opte souvent pour des structures de phrases
longues et complexes avec l’ambition de
créer un rythme unique. Grâce à l’usage
du discours indirect libre, il s’efface
derrière son œuvre qui doit donner l’illusion
d’exister par elle-même. Il utilise de
manière magistrale le style indirect libre
: il n’introduit pas les paroles et les
pensées du personnage avec un verbe, si bien
que les voix du personnage et celle du narrateur
s’enchevêtrent. Enfin, il est habilement
ironique.
La sophistication de la prose de Madame Bovary
peut rebuter un lecteur du XXIe siècle, mais
elle fait de Flaubert un des plus grands stylistes
de la littérature française.
Je vous résume rapidement le roman.
Flaubert s’est inspiré, sur le conseil
de deux de ses amis, d’un fait divers récent,
le suicide de l’épouse d’un officier.
Il en tire l'histoire d'Emma Rouault, une
jeune femme qui rêve de la vie passionnante
et romantique qu’elle a découverte dans
ses lectures de jeunesse. Elle épouse Charles
Bovary, un médecin de province, et malheureusement,
elle se sent rapidement déçue par leur vie
monotone et sans relief. Emma fait la connaissance
de diverses personnalités locales, dont le
pharmacien Monsieur Homais, le curé Bournisien,
le clerc de notaire Léon Dupuis et le libertin
Rodolphe Boulanger. Elle sombre dans la dépression
et entame des liaisons avec le libertin et
le notaire — mais ces relations se révèlent
décevantes. Emma s’était endettée pour
ses achats compulsifs de vêtements et d’objets
luxueux et pour financer ses relations extraconjugales.
Et un jour, le marchand qui lui a prêté
de l’argent exige d'être remboursé. Incapable
de payer ses dettes et désespérée, Emma
se suicide. Son mari meurt de chagrin. Berthe,
leur fille, est confiée à une tante et envoyée
travailler dans une filature de coton.
Madame Bovary fait de Flaubert le plus grand
auteur du dernier tiers du XIXe siècle parce
qu’il lance la nouvelle orientation littéraire
à laquelle vont se rallier ses contemporains.
Pour faire simple, son roman symbolise le
passage du romantisme au réalisme. Flaubert
avait auparavant écrit un roman dans le style
lyrique propre au romantisme — mais ses
amis lui avaient conseillé de le jeter au
feu, parce que le romantisme était passé
de mode. Les lecteurs voulaient désormais
qu’on les intéresse à la réalité contemporaine.
Flaubert a suivi leur conseil à contrecœur
parce qu’il vomit la bourgeoisie. Il met
donc en évidence dans Madame Bovary la vulgarité
de la bourgeoisie de province, la bassesse
de son pragmatisme. Cela fait de son roman
une des plus célèbres critiques du mode
de vie bourgeois dans la littérature mondiale.
Mais l’idée plus profonde qui ressort du
destin d’Emma Bovary, ce sont les ravages
du « bovarysme » évoqué par Emmanuel Macron,
c’est-à-dire le désir que l'existence
quotidienne ressemble à ce qu'on lit dans
les romans. Flaubert prend ainsi position
sur la très vieille, et très importante
question de l’influence de la fiction sur
la réalité. Si son héroïne est malheureuse,
c’est parce que les romans qu’elle a lus
dans sa jeunesse ont fait naître chez elle
des attentes irréalistes.
________________
NEUVIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Les Misérables (1862), Victor Hugo
En 2019 sort un film intitulé Les Misérables.
Le réalisateur français Ladj Ly transpose
les thèmes du roman de Victor Hugo — la
pauvreté, l'injustice et la violence policière
— dans la banlieue parisienne du début
du XXIe siècle. Le long métrage, qui dépasse
le million d'entrées en salles, montre que
le chef-d’œuvre publié il y a plus de
150 ans est toujours une référence pertinente
pour parler des inégalités sociales.
Les Misérables est un des romans les plus
populaires de la littérature française malgré
ses 2600 pages — Hugo qualifiait son livre
de « montagne » (mais il existe aujourd’hui
des versions abrégées de quelques centaines
de pages).
Sur la forme, la prose de Hugo (qui est le
chef de file du romantisme) est très poétique,
pleine de métaphores. Elle est parfois crue
lorsqu’il s’agit de faire sentir la difficulté
des conditions de vie des personnages. Hugo
donne une voix unique à chaque personnage
grâce à des accents, des dialectes et des
tics de langage — ce qui donne beaucoup
de réalisme à l’histoire. Enfin, les descriptions
détaillées ne sont pas rares, ce qui va
bien sûr rebuter un lecteur du XXIe siècle.
La description des égouts de Paris est si
précise et détaillée que le lecteur peut
presque sentir l'odeur putride et entendre
le bruit de l'eau.
L'action se déroule en France, au début
du XIXe siècle. Victor Hugo raconte, pendant
5 tomes, le destin de Jean Valjean, un forçat
échappé du bagne.
Frappé par la générosité de l’évêque
Myriel à son égard, il essaie désormais
de faire le bien autour de lui. Il promet
à Fantine, une pauvre femme mourante, de
prendre soin de Cosette, sa fille exploitée
par un couple d’aubergistes, les Thénardier.
Seulement, son passé et l’inspecteur Javert
le rattrapent. Jean Valjean ne sauve donc
la petite Cosette qu’après s’être évadé
de prison. Il se dissimule avec elle dans
un couvent.
Quelques années plus tard, le jeune Marius
tombe amoureux de Cosette. Lors de l’insurrection
républicaine du 5 juin 1832, Jean Valjean
sauve à la fois l’inspecteur Javert, ainsi
que Marius, qu’il ramène sans connaissance
à travers les égoûts de Paris. En revanche,
le petit Gavroche, personnage qui symbolise
les enfants des rues parisiennes, meurt héroïquement
sur les barricades.
Marius épouse Cosette, puis il veut l’éloigner
de Jean Valjean après avoir découvert son
passé. Alors Jean Valjean se meurt, dans
la solitude et le chagrin. Mais lorsque Marius
apprend tardivement que le forçat qu’il
veut fuir lui a sauvé la vie, il se rend
auprès de lui avec Cosette. Ayant revue la
petite fille qu’il avait prise sous sa protection,
Jean Valjean peut « mourir comme un saint
».
Les Misérables marque la littérature française
parce que c’est un récit aux qualités
exceptionnelles. En effet, il mêle le réalisme
(dans la description de la pauvreté du début
du XIXe siècle), l’épopée (dans le récit
de grandes aventures, notamment le destin
de Valjean), et il mêle également l’amour
(romantique, mais aussi familial).
Le but essentiel des Misérables est de dénoncer
la misère. C’est un roman social (et donc
aussi politique), car Hugo y décrit les conditions
et les conflits des différentes classes sociales
(il s’est beaucoup documenté pour cela).
Il écrit dans la préface : « Tant qu’il
y aura sur la terre ignorance et misère,
des livres de la nature de celui-ci pourront
ne pas être inutiles ».
Hugo dénonce plus précisément l’exploitation
de l’homme par l’homme, l’indifférence
à la misère et la répressivité du système
(il considère que la peine de mort est une
hérésie). À ses yeux, la solution réside
dans l’instruction des masses dès l’enfance.
Enfin, l’influence des Misérables dépasse
le champ de la littérature. Ses personnages
sont si célèbres qu’ils sont devenus des
noms communs dans le langage courant : on
parle par exemple d’une « Cosette » pour
désigner une jeune fille surexploitée par
ses employeurs ou ses parents ; on parle aussi
d’un « Thénardier » pour désigner un
exploiteur, et dans un sens plus général
un salaud.
L’histoire des Misérables fascine même
à l’étranger. Le livre est très populaire
en Asie, où il a même été adapté en manga.
________________
DIXIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Vingt Mille Lieues sous les mers (1869), Jules
Verne
Ce roman était le livre préféré du célèbre
explorateur polaire Ernest Shackleton lorsqu’il
était enfant : il y a puisé son inspiration.
Alors, quand son équipage et lui sont piégés
dans les glaces de l'Antarctique en 1914,
il fait passer des exemplaires à ses hommes.
La légende dit que Vingt Mille Lieues sous
les mers leur a donné la force mentale pour
sortir de leur situation désespérée.
Sur le plan de la forme, le style de Jules
Verne a plusieurs qualités. La narration
à la première personne permet au lecteur
de voir le monde à travers les yeux du protagoniste,
le professeur Aronnax. Les avantages de cette
solution, ce sont une meilleure immersion
dans l’histoire et une identification plus
forte avec les personnages. Bref, on a l’impression
d’y être.
Une autre qualité du style de Verne, c’est
le métissage de la poésie et de la science.
D’un côté, il dépeint avec poésie les
paysages sous-marins et les créatures qui
y vivent. Ses descriptions détaillées immergent
le lecteur dans le monde merveilleux et dangereux
des profondeurs de l'océan. Il réussit à
créer une atmosphère mystérieuse et fascinante.
Et de l’autre côté, Verne évoque parfois
la vie sous-marine avec des termes scientifiques.
Il parle également des machines et des inventions
de l’époque (comme le scaphandre autonome
et le sous-marin lui-même) avec un langage
précis et technique.
Après, la prose de Jules Verne ne plaît
pas à tout le monde. Le lecteur du XXIe siècle
peut être ennuyé par la lenteur de la narration
; il peut trouver que les descriptions nuisent
à la fluidité du récit, qu’il y en a
trop par rapport à l’action.
Mais bon, la langue de Verne est quand même
claire et simple, facile à lire et à comprendre.
Ce n’est pas pour rien que ses romans ont
été si populaires auprès d'un large public.
Maintenant, je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
En 1866, la presse relate l'apparition d'une
créature marine monstrueuse qui causerait
des naufrages. Elle sème la terreur dans
les océans du monde entier. Et concrètement,
c’est un problème pour les compagnies d’assurance
maritime.
Pierre Aronnax, un professeur de biologie
marine, est invité à participer à une expédition
visant à traquer la bête. Aronnax embarque
sur l’Abraham Lincoln avec son fidèle domestique
Conseil et le harponneur Ned Land, qui est
originaire de Québec.
Au cours de l'expédition, ils sont attaqués
par la créature et échouent sur son dos.
Il s’agit en fait d'un sous-marin futuriste,
le Nautilus. Aronnax, Conseil et Ned Land
y sont faits prisonniers par le mystérieux
capitaine Nemo, un homme qui a fui la surface
et la société. Ils découvrent l’intérêt
scientifique de Nemo pour les fonds marins,
mais ils comprennent également qu’il utilise
le Nautilus comme une arme de guerre. Il attaque
des navires afin de se venger de l’humanité.
Les trois prisonniers cherchent un moyen de
s'échapper du Nautilus tout en explorant
les merveilles du monde sous-marin. Ils découvrent
des créatures étranges et merveilleuses,
des trésors engloutis, l’Atlantide, et
des épaves d'anciens navires ; ils s'aventurent
sur les îles du Pacifique et la banquise
du pôle Sud ; ils chassent dans les forêts
sous-marines et combattent des calmars géants.
Finalement, Aronnax, Ned et Conseil réussissent
à s'échapper du Nautilus. Mais on ne sait
pas ce qu’il adviendra de Nemo et de son
sous-marin.
Vingt Mille Lieues sous les mers est certainement
le meilleur roman de Jules Verne.
Son importance dans l’histoire de la littérature
tient essentiellement à l’impulsion qu’il
donne au genre de la science-fiction (qu’on
peut définir par le fait que l’auteur imagine
une société future née de certains progrès
techniques). Dans ce roman, Jules Verne vulgarise
les sciences et les technologies de son époque.
Il met notamment en évidence l’importance
de l’électricité. Et puis il anticipe
aussi le progrès technique. Il imagine des
appareils futuristes, comme les prochaines
générations de sous-marin.
Ce roman a révolutionné la littérature
populaire en introduisant des thèmes scientifiques
et techniques dans la fiction. Il a ouvert
la voie à une nouvelle génération de romans
d'aventures. C’est pour ça que Jules Verne
est considéré comme un des deux pères fondateurs
(avec le Britannique Herbert George Wells)
du roman de science-fiction.
Vingt Mille Lieues sous les mers a plus généralement
eu une influence importante dans la culture
populaire occidentale. Il passe d’ailleurs
pour un des livres les plus traduits au monde
(je dis « passe » parce qu’il n’existe
pas de statistiques fiables).
Son influence culturelle tient à deux choses.
Tout d’abord, il a promu la science et la
technologie dans l’imaginaire collectif.
Et puis le capitaine Nemo, un des personnages
les plus célèbres de Jules Verne, est un
peu devenu un archétype. Il incarne l’homme
solitaire qui s’oppose à la société.
Il est aussi un héros écologique, car Verne
lui fait dénoncer la dégradation de l’environnement
(en particulier la dégradation de la mer,
dont il dit qu’elle est « le vaste réservoir
de la nature »).
________________
ONZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Germinal (1885), Émile Zola
Nous sommes en 1912, lors du procès pour
diffamation d’Anatole France, l’un des
écrivains les plus populaires de l’époque.
Le juge lui demande s’il a lu Germinal de
Zola, avec lequel il s’est réconcilié
à l’occasion de l'affaire Dreyfus. Bien
sûr, qu’il l’a lu. Le juge lui demande
alors s’il ne pense pas que ce roman a incité
à la révolte. « Non, Monsieur le juge,
répond Anatole France, Germinal n’a pas
incité à la révolte, il a empêché la
révolte ».
En effet, ce roman a eu une grande influence
politique. En donnant à voir les conditions
de travail épouvantables des mineurs, il
a montré qu’une réforme sociale était
nécessaire.
Dans ce roman, la prose a deux caractéristiques
principales : le réalisme et le naturalisme.
Le style est réaliste parce que Zola décrit
crûment les conditions de travail et de vie
des mineurs (leurs vêtements, par exemple).
Une scène m’avait marqué : de mémoire,
une adolescente prolétaire qui se donne rapidement
à un homme dans un coin, dans un buisson
ou derrière un arbre. L’idée que cela
véhicule, c’est que les ouvriers s’accouplent
comme des animaux. Bien évidemment, une telle
scène choque le bourgeois de l’époque.
Le réalisme de Zola se retrouve encore jusque
dans le choix des mots : il n’hésite pas
à se servir de termes vulgaires pour faire
sentir la violence du quotidien des mineurs.
Comme je vous l’ai dit, son style est également
naturaliste.
Le naturalisme, c’est la doctrine esthétique
qui proscrit toute idéalisation de la réalité.
Il faut au contraire faire ressortir la « nature
», au sens des faits typiques de l’expérience
humaine. Et ces faits typiques doivent montrer
que l’homme obéit aux lois de la nature
(celles de son corps, notamment) et qu’il
est le produit de son milieu. Par exemple,
qu’une adolescente s’accouple rapidement
derrière un buisson comme une bête, cela
s’explique à la fois par son instinct de
reproduction et par le dénuement dans lequel
vivent les prolétaires, qui résulte ultimement
de forces économiques et sociales. La comparaison
des mineurs à des animaux (qui exprime le
point de vue des bourgeois) est récurrente
dans le roman.
Zola recourt plus généralement à des métaphores
pour évoquer la souffrance des mineurs. Il
compare par exemple la mine à un monstre
à l'appétit immense, qui avale les hommes
et les digère lentement.
Son style peut sembler lourd à un lecteur
du XXIe siècle, mais il est quand même bien
clair comparé à d’autres auteurs de l’époque.
Zola est même un des auteurs que je recommande
aux personnes qui souhaitent lire pour améliorer
leur expression écrite, parce que sa langue
est à la fois claire, classique et accessible.
Je passe au résumé de l’histoire.
Le jeune Étienne Lantier est le fils de Gervaise
Macquart, le personnage principal d’un autre
best-seller naturaliste de Zola, L’Assommoir,
qui dépeint les ravages de la misère et
de l’alcoolisme chez les ouvriers (Zola
avait relié entre eux beaucoup de personnages
de son grand cycle romanesque Les Rougon-Macquart).
Nous savons donc déjà que le jeune Étienne
Lantier a eu une enfance compliquée, entre
le départ de son père, les difficultés
financières de sa mère, et l’alcoolisme
de son beau-père.
Au début de Germinal, il cherche un nouvel
emploi. Il s’est fait virer du précédent,
dans les chemins de fer du Nord de la France,
parce qu’il a donné une gifle à son employeur.
Il se fait embaucher dans les mines de Montsou,
où les conditions de travail sont horribles.
Il habite chez une famille de mineurs, les
Maheu. Il tombe amoureux de leur fille aînée,
Catherine — mais celle-ci se refuse à quitter
l’ouvrier brutal qu’elle fréquente.
Le penchant pour la révolte d’Étienne
se réveille lorsque l’entreprise qui l’emploie
veut leur imposer une baisse de salaire. Il
pousse les mineurs à la grève et leur transmet
son désir de justice sociale.
Mais la confrontation avec l’entreprise
est très dure. Les dirigeants refusent la
négociation et les ouvriers résistent pendant
plusieurs semaines. Le mouvement continue
même après que les soldats ont rétabli
l’ordre. Les ouvriers en viennent à défier
les soldats. Ceux-ci tirent alors sur les
manifestants, tuant notamment Maheu, qui héberge
Étienne.
Certains d’entre eux ayant perdu la vie
dans le mouvement, les mineurs se résignent
à reprendre le travail. Alors survient un
événement qui fait prendre un tournant au
destin d’Étienne. Un anarchiste sabote
le puits, condamnant de nombreux mineurs à
mourir dans l'effondrement et l'inondation
des galeries. Bloqué avec Catherine (la femme
dont il est amoureux) et Chaval (l’amant
violent de Catherine), Étienne est le seul
à sortir vivant.
Il repart à Paris pour défendre la cause
ouvrière. Si les mineurs de Montsou sont
retournés au travail, ils sont désormais
animés d’une conscience politique.
Pour faire simple, Germinal est le roman de
la lutte des classes, celui qui symbolise
l’arrivée du marxisme en France. Zola dénonce
les conditions de travail épouvantables des
mineurs dans le Nord de la France, et il montre
que cette misère ne peut qu’accoucher de
la révolte.
C’est d’ailleurs le sens du titre du roman
: « germinal » est l’adjectif correspondant
au nom commun « germination », qui désigne
le développement d’une nouvelle plante
à partir d’une semence. L’idée du titre,
c’est donc que le sort épouvantable des
prolétaires est la semence de la révolution
à venir. On retrouve également cette idée
dans le fait que « Germinal » est un mois
du calendrier révolutionnaire français correspondant
au début du printemps, et donc à la renaissance
de la nature (et par là, le titre du roman
est aussi une référence à la Révolution
française, la plus célèbre des révoltes).
Ce roman est également important dans l’histoire
de la littérature pour une seconde raison
: il est emblématique du courant naturaliste.
Les conditions de vie des ouvriers sont un
bon sujet pour la conception de l’écriture
de Zola. Le romancier naturaliste doit écrire
sous la dictée de la réalité pour faire
œuvre de science. Il décrit l’humanité
ordinaire en s’effaçant derrière l’histoire
— il ne peut pas se permettre de commenter
ou d’interpréter les faits comme le faisait
Balzac. Si on suit Zola, un roman n’est
presque plus une œuvre de fiction.
Mais la portée de Germinal dépasse la littérature
et la France. Les nombreuses traductions lui
ont permis d’être lu dans le monde entier.
C’est un classique de la littérature mondiale.
Et puis c’est aussi une œuvre politique.
Ce que signifie la réponse d’Anatole France
au juge qui lui demande si Germinal n’a
pas incité à la révolte, c’est que ce
roman a au contraire fait prendre conscience
aux élites françaises de la nécessité
d’améliorer le sort des ouvriers (soit
par humanité, soit pour éviter la révolution
!).
________________
DOUZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Bel-Ami (1885), Guy de Maupassant
Début 2009 paraît Belle-Amie — mais B
E deux L E, et « amie » avec un E — une
biographie à charge contre Rachida Dati,
la ministre de la Justice de Nicolas Sarkozy.
Alors que cette ministre est à l’époque
une icône de la méritocratie et un symbole
de la diversité, le livre dénonce l’arrivisme
de son parcours, qui devrait tout à l’intrigue
et la séduction, en le comparant au destin
de Georges Duroy, le personnage du roman de
Maupassant.
On retrouve dans le style de Maupassant la
simplicité et le réalisme du courant naturaliste
parce qu’il a brièvement évolué dans
l’orbite de Zola. Il dépeint la haute société
parisienne de la fin du XIXe siècle dans
un langage direct, sans fioritures. Il décrit
les intérieurs des appartements, les vêtements,
les gestes et les comportements avec une grande
précision, ce qui permet au lecteur de s'immerger
dans le microcosme de l’élite parisienne.
Une autre caractéristique du style de Maupassant
dans Bel-Ami, c’est qu’il est efficace
pour conserver l’attention du lecteur. Par
exemple, il met en place des retournements
de situation pour maintenir la tension narrative.
Sur le plan du choix des mots, enfin, Maupassant
sait, comme tout écrivain talentueux, produire
des images évocatrices. Par exemple, il compare
à plusieurs reprises Georges Duroy à un
prédateur sauvage, soit un animal insaisissable
et opportuniste.
Je passe à l’histoire du roman.
Georges Duroy vient de passer plusieurs années
en Algérie en tant que militaire. Comme beaucoup
d’ambitieux, il monte à Paris pour faire
fortune — et comme beaucoup d’ambitieux,
la dure réalité de la jungle parisienne
déçoit ses attentes. Il doit se contenter
d’un poste minable à la compagnie des chemins
de fer du Nord.
Mais le destin le favorise lorsqu’il tombe
sur un ami perdu de vue. Comme Charles Forestier
est rédacteur en chef à La vie française,
il y embauche Georges comme journaliste. Mais
voilà, Georges n’a pas le niveau pour écrire
— il a besoin de l’aide de la belle et
riche femme de son ami, Madeleine Forestier
— dont il tombe amoureux — pour réussir
à boucler les articles. En plus de lui donner
un travail, son ami le présente à la société
parisienne.
Georges Duroy monte rapidement les échelons
grâce à ses talents de séducteur et à
son réseau. Il noue des amitiés intéressées,
et il fait bien sûr des jaloux. Il accède
à la reconnaissance sociale en épousant
la fille d'un riche homme d'affaires, ce qui
ne l’empêche pas de poursuivre une relation
amoureuse avec une ancienne maîtresse de
son ami. À un moment, ses multiples intrigues
amoureuses l’amènent à devoir choisir
entre vivre des sentiments authentiques et
la réussite sociale.
Georges Duroy s’est bien imposé dans les
élites parisiennes, mais il réalise qu’il
a corrompu son âme pour parvenir à ses fins.
Pour faire simple, Bel-Ami est le roman de
référence de la littérature française
sur le thème de l’arrivisme. Maupassant
dépeint l’immoralité de la vie sociale
parisienne de l’époque, où le succès
ne dépend pas des compétences ni de la morale.
Il analyse la psychologie de l’ambition
à travers les conflits intérieurs de Georges
Duroy, qui se rend compte de la corruption
de son âme. Son évolution est symbolisée
par les scènes où il se regarde dans le
miroir (au début de son ascension, il se
découvre en homme du monde à travers les
miroirs quand il gravit les escaliers pour
se rendre chez Forestier).
Bel-Ami est également important dans l’histoire
de la littérature française parce qu’il
est emblématique du courant réaliste. Maupassant
évoque le contexte social et politique de
son époque (il fait par exemple des références
à l’expansion coloniale de la France) ; il
décrit les mœurs de son époque ; il dépeint
des microcosmes qu’il connaît, comme celui
des journaux de son époque. Il écrira que
le romancier réaliste doit « donner la vision
plus complète, plus saisissante, plus probante
que la réalité même ».
Le succès littéraire de Bel-Ami a rapporté
beaucoup d’argent à Maupassant. Son histoire
se distingue des autres histoires d’ambitieux
(celles de Balzac, par exemple) par le fait
qu’elle représente l’arrivisme « à
l’état pur » : Georges Duroy n’a aucune
compétence à offrir, il est simplement séduisant.
Elle symbolise par là le penchant à l’immoralité
des élites.
Elle sera adaptée de nombreuses fois à la
télévision et au cinéma.
________________
TREIZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
L'Immoraliste (1902), André Gide
En 1922, le régime fasciste de Mussolini
interdit ce roman. Il estime que sa représentation
de l’homosexualité et sa critique de la
morale traditionnelle sont trop subversives
pour la société italienne. Les milieux littéraires
protestent — en vain. La psychologie humaine
étant ce qu’elle est, l’interdiction
renforce la renommée internationale du livre.
En Italie même, des exemplaires clandestins
continuent de circuler sous le nez des autorités
fascistes.
La controverse n’est pas étonnante, car
le titre annonce la couleur : un « immoraliste
», c’est quelqu’un qui professe l’immoralisme,
c’est-à-dire une doctrine qui se définit
simplement par son opposition à la morale
établie, c’est-à-dire par la controverse.
Bref, le titre du roman porte en lui-même
l’idée de la controverse.
L’Immoraliste brise également les conventions
sur la forme.
Le style d’André Gide est avant-gardiste,
c’est-à-dire qu’il est précurseur dans
la rénovation de la prose. On peut le qualifier
d’« expérimental ». Il recourt au symbolisme
pour évoquer des images complexes et paradoxales
(je rappelle qu’un symbole, c’est un signe
qui renvoie à une autre chose à laquelle
il est lié par un rapport de ressemblance).
Par exemple, Gide décrit un espace naturel
de manière à suggérer la coexistence de
la beauté et de la décadence (oui, c’est
compliqué). Autre innovation, les événements
sont filtrés à travers la subjectivité
du narrateur. Enfin, la langue de Gide — son
vocabulaire, en particulier — sa langue
est d’une grande richesse poétique, comme
le reconnaîtront de grands écrivains. Et
la beauté du style est d’autant plus frappante
qu’elle contraste avec la sombreur des thèmes.
Que retenir du fond du roman ?
C’est l’histoire de Michel, un érudit
passionné par l’histoire ancienne, mais
qui vit de manière très conventionnelle.
Fraîchement marié à Marceline, il part
avec elle en voyage de noces. En Afrique du
Nord, il tombe malade, si malade qu’il craint
d’y passer. Mais plutôt que la mort, il
vit sa convalescence comme une nouvelle naissance.
Une fois rétabli, il change de perspective
sur la vie — notamment sur le plan moral,
d’où le titre du roman. Alors qu’il était
un érudit peu porté sur la chair, le désir
renaît en lui (on retrouve là l’idée
de la volonté de puissance de Nietzsche,
dont Gide était fan). On comprend également
l’homosexualité latente du personnage,
attiré par la spectaculaire santé des jeunes
garçons arabes qui l’accompagnent au cours
de promenades.
De retour en Normandie, où il doit reprendre
son mode de vie conventionnel, il se rend
compte qu’il est attiré par ce qu’il
y a sous le vernis de la civilisation. Il
fréquente des hommes qui ne vivent pas selon
les conventions. Lui-même, il n’est plus
l’homme civilisé qu’il était. Après
la fausse couche de sa femme, il fuit son
existence bourgeoise à travers l’Afrique,
puis l’Europe (où sa femme trouvera la
mort).
L’immoraliste marque la littérature française
à la fois sur le fond et sur la forme. Il
explore des thèmes controversés, tout particulièrement
l’homosexualité — il est un des premiers
à aborder ouvertement la question — ce
qui lui vaudra d’être interdit dans plusieurs
pays. Et si Gide réussit à évoquer des
sujets controversés de manière subtile,
c’est grâce à l’originalité de son
style expérimental. Il ne faut cependant
pas réduire cette innovation au symbolisme,
parce que Gide lui-même était gêné par
l’excessive abstraction du symbolisme.
Ce roman est encore emblématique à un autre
égard : l’égotisme des écrivains du tournant
du XXe siècle, c’est-à-dire leur propension
à s’étudier eux-mêmes et à parler d’eux-mêmes.
C’est l’époque de l’émergence de la
psychanalyse. L’œuvre, comme l’analyste,
est censée délivrer l’auteur de ses névroses.
Elle devient le lieu où il dénonce tout
ce qui fait, ou a fait, obstacle à son épanouissement
personnel (les problèmes non résolus dans
l'enfance, les blocages à l’origine des
conflits psychiques, les conflits familiaux).
Gide inspirera beaucoup d’auteurs à dénoncer
l'entrave de la société au libre déploiement
du Moi. Il passera aussi pour un précurseur
du surréalisme dans la mesure où son style
refléterait l’activité spontanée de l’esprit
(dans la liberté des associations d’idées,
notamment).
En résumé, L’Immoraliste est un roman
incontournable parce qu’il promeut de nouveaux
thèmes et une nouvelle manière, subjective,
symbolique et subtile, d’en parler. André
Gide est, avec Marcel Proust, le plus grand
romancier français du XXe siècle.
________________
QUATORZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
À la recherche du temps perdu (1913), Marcel
Proust
Marcel Proust écrit dès l'adolescence et
n'embrasse aucune carrière après ses études
(ce qui signifie surtout, vous l’avez compris,
qu’il n’a pas besoin de travailler). Depuis
sa jeunesse, il fréquente des salons aristocratiques
où il rencontre artistes et écrivains, ce
qui lui vaut une réputation de dilettante
mondain. C’est à cause de cette réputation
que Gallimard refuse le 1er tome du roman
qui sera le plus grand de la littérature
française au XXe siècle. Grasset, elle,
accepte de publier le 1er tome, mais à compte
d’auteur, c’est-à-dire que Proust paie
tous les frais de sa poche (mais ça tombe
bien, il a les moyens).
Gaston Gallimard, le fondateur de la maison
d’édition, se rend ensuite compte qu’il
a loupé un bon coup. Donc c’est lui qui
publie le 2ème tome.
Il y aura en tout 7 tomes : Du côté de chez
Swann ; À l'ombre des jeunes filles en fleurs
; Le Côté de Guermantes ; Sodome et Gomorrhe
; La Prisonnière ; Albertine disparue ; Le
Temps retrouvé.
Les deux derniers tomes ont été publiés
après la mort de Proust grâce aux soins
du frère, mais Proust lui-même les aurait
certainement repris.
J’ai lu les 7 tomes de La Recherche au début
de la vingtaine, au cours d’un été où
j’ai passé beaucoup de temps à lire au
soleil au jardin du Luxembourg. Pour être
honnête avec vous, j’ai souffert pour aller
jusqu’au bout et j’ai très moyennement
aimé. D’un côté, Proust écrit très
bien — c’est vrai ; il analyse finement
les individus et les situations ; et il dit
beaucoup de choses pénétrantes sur la nature
humaine. Mais de l’autre côté, comme j’aime
l’idéal de concision du français classique,
j’ai trouvé les phrases, les paragraphes,
et plus généralement les tomes beaucoup
trop longs. Et c’est d’autant plus long
que l’histoire est ennuyeuse et que les
personnages ne sont pas inspirants. Après,
le livre date d’une époque où la concurrence
n’était pas si féroce parmi les producteurs
de divertissement, c’est-à-dire que les
lecteurs arrivaient à se plonger dans un
livre si long pour la simple et bonne raison
qu’ils n’avaient pas beaucoup d’autres
options pour se divertir.
Quoi retenir du fond, maintenant ?
Honnêtement, c’est pas passionnant.
L’histoire de La Recherche mêle la biographie
du narrateur à la mise en scène de la société
mondaine des dernières années du XIXe siècle.
Le narrateur est, comme Proust, un jeune bourgeois
hypersensible dont l’ambition est d’être
écrivain. Seulement, il perd son temps en
mondanités, parmi l’aristocratie ou dans
les lieux de villégiature à la mode. Il
découvre en grandissant la dynamique des
relations sociales, et en particulier celle
de l’amour. Coupé du monde par la maladie
et la guerre, il prend conscience de la vanité
de sa vie mondaine et se convainc de son aptitude
à enfin devenir écrivain.
L’épisode le plus célèbre de la série
de romans est celui dit de « la madeleine
de Proust ». Dans Du côté de chez Swann,
le narrateur décrit comment la réminiscence
d’un rituel de son enfance a été déclenchée
en trempant le petit gâteau dans du thé
: « Et tout d'un coup le souvenir m'est apparu.
Ce goût, c'était celui du petit morceau
de madeleine que le dimanche matin à Combray
[...] ma tante Léonie m'offrait après
l'avoir trempé dans son infusion de thé
ou de tilleul. » « Madeleine de Proust » est
devenue une expression courante : elle désigne
un petit événement qui fait ressurgir d'heureux
souvenirs d'enfance.
De manière plus générale, le roman est
une réflexion psychologique sur la littérature,
la mémoire et le temps. L’histoire montre
qu’on connaît les autres à travers la
sélection arbitraire, par notre esprit, de
certains traits. Ainsi, dans la passion amoureuse,
on n'aime pas l'être réel, mais une construction
de notre esprit. Mais on peut retrouver la
vérité par l’introspection. Le titre À
la recherche du temps perdu résume l’idée
majeure, à savoir qu’on peut découvrir
le sens profond de son existence en explorant
ses souvenirs.
Dans l’histoire de la littérature, La Recherche
marque un tournant sur le plan des thèmes.
Elle symbolise l’égotisme des romanciers,
c’est-à-dire leur propension à s’étudier
eux-mêmes et à parler d’eux-mêmes.
À la publication du 1er tome en 1913, Marcel
Proust passe pour un novateur (les premières
critiques le comparent à Montaigne). Le destin
de la littérature du XXe siècle est tout
entier contenu dans une phrase du dernier
tome, intitulé Le Temps retrouvé : « Je
compris que tous ces matériaux de l'œuvre
littéraire, c'était ma vie passée. »
Le sens de cette révolution littéraire,
c’est qu’écrire devient synonyme de mettre
en scène son individualité. Le critique
littéraire Fernand Vandérem dit peu après
la Première Guerre mondiale que les romans
sont devenus « des hottes à souvenirs et
à impressions personnelles ». Plus le siècle
avance, plus cela sera vrai. La « mise en
abîme », dans l’ouvrage, de l’auteur
en train de composer son livre — cette configuration
devient de plus en plus fréquente, puis se
banalise. Les deux grands auteurs du XXe siècle,
Marcel Proust et André Gide, recourent tous
les deux à cette configuration.
Après le premier quart du XXe siècle, les
romanciers modernes répètent inlassablement
le modèle de La Recherche. Ainsi, Marcel
Proust est devenu un des noms les plus prestigieux
de la littérature tout court en parlant de
sa vie personnelle et en disséquant ses états
d’âme sur des milliers de pages. Désormais,
l’écrivain ne prétend pas accéder à
l’universel, être la voix de la vérité.
Il respecte scrupuleusement la sensation.
Comme Proust, il préfère décrire les choses
telles que les perçoit la conscience du narrateur.
________________
Vous aimez les gros manuels ?
Je sais bien, c’est pas une partie de plaisir.
Mais comment faire si vous voulez découvrir
les idées d’Aristote, par exemple ?
Eh bien allez sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Vous tapez « Aristote » dans la barre de
recherche, et vous avez les synthèses, des
synthèses très claires des meilleures idées
d’Aristote.
Rédigées avec amour et beaucoup de café,
par votre serviteur.
Et comme le nom l’indique, 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n’est pas que de la
philo.
Vous trouverez aussi les meilleures idées
en économie, en littérature, en histoire,
en science politique, en psychologie, etc.
Alors maintenant, que faire de ces gros manuels
?
Alors moi je les garde, parce qu’ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la bibliothèque
quand je tourne des vidéos.
Mais vous, vous pouvez vous en servir comme
support pour poser la casserole, ou bien pour
faire de la musculation, si vous n’aimez
pas les haltères classiques.
[Moi en train de soulever de gros manuels]
« C’est moins fatiguant que de les lire
! ».
Vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la pensée.
Allez simplement sur le site 1000 idées de
culture générale.
________________
QUINZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Voyage au bout de la nuit (1932), Louis-Ferdinand
Céline
La publication de Voyage au bout de la nuit
en 1932 ébranle la vie littéraire française.
Le mélange de violence et d’originalité
de ce roman, le premier d’un auteur écrivant
sous pseudonyme, ne laisse personne indifférent
: les critiques sont abasourdis ; les écrivains
se partagent en deux camps, les partisans
admiratifs et les adversaires scandalisés.
Le livre sort tellement du lot par rapport
à ceux publiés à la même période que
le prestigieux prix Goncourt lui semble promis.
Un membre du jury raconte que la décision
avait été prise, mais que les jurés sont
revenus dessus par peur du scandale.
Voyage au bout de la nuit représente une
révolution sur le plan de la forme. Le style
de Céline y est unique par son anticonformisme.
Des thèses entières ont été écrites sur
l’innovation que représente cette prose,
mais sa dimension essentielle est que Céline
ne respecte pas la différence entre l’écrit
et l’oral. La conception de l’écriture
héritée de l’époque classique présuppose
que la parole écrite est plus noble que la
parole orale, et par conséquent qu’on ennoblit
son expression en parlant comme on écrit,
avec ordre et clarté. Céline, lui, fait
l’inverse : il puise dans la langue parlée
pour renouveler la langue écrite. L’effet
est double : on y gagne sur le plan poétique,
avec des images originales et du rythme ; mais
en même temps, la « vulgarité » de l’oral
pénètre la langue écrite.
En pratique, cela donne de l’argot, des
jurons (qui choquent les critiques de l’époque),
ou encore un usage (qui peut paraître excessif)
des petits points. Céline crée également
des néologismes, comme « voyoucratie », ou
« sacriléger ».
Enfin, la langue parlée est d’autant plus
frappante dans Voyage au bout de la nuit que
Céline est également capable d’écrire
avec un français classique châtié. L’alternance
entre
les deux registres de langues crée un puissant
effet de contraste.
Que retenir de l’histoire de ce roman, maintenant
?
En fait, c’est l’autobiographie romancée
de Céline — donc un mélange de vrai et
de faux.
On suit les aventures de Ferdinand Bardamu,
l’alter ego de l’auteur. Le roman commence
par son enfance dans les faubourgs de Paris,
puis suit ses voyages en Afrique et en Amérique,
et sa participation à la Première Guerre
mondiale. Tout au long de ses voyages, Bardamu
rencontre des personnages marginaux, des prostituées,
des colonisateurs brutaux et des intellectuels
égocentriques. La structure de la narration
n’est pas linéaire — c’est une succession
de situations, avec des flash-back, des ellipses
et des sauts dans le temps qui illustrent
l’incapacité du héros à donner un sens
global à son existence.
Les thèmes du roman sont particulièrement
sombres : l'absurdité de la guerre, la misère,
la corruption, ou encore l'exploitation coloniale.
Bardamu est confronté à la mort, à la maladie
et à la folie, cherchant désespérément
un sens à sa vie. Il retourne finalement
à Paris, où il se résigne à sa condition,
et plus généralement à celle de l'humanité.
Cette conclusion explique le titre : la vie
est un « voyage au bout de la nuit », au
sens où elle se résume à explorer la médiocrité
et la misère de la condition humaine. Historiquement,
l’expression « voyage au bout de la nuit
» est tirée d’un couplet chanté par un
soldat de Napoléon au cours de la bataille
de la Bérézina : « Notre vie est un voyage
/ Dans l'Hiver et dans la Nuit / Nous cherchons
notre passage / Dans le Ciel où rien ne luit
».
En quoi ce roman est-il incontournable dans
l’histoire de la littérature française
?
Sur le fond, il passe pour un chef-d’œuvre
nihiliste. Le destin de Bardamu illustre une
conviction qui se diffuse à l’époque : la
vie n’a pas de sens en soi. Le pessimisme
qui émane de la prose de Céline témoigne
d’une lucidité sans concession. En particulier,
Voyage au bout de la nuit est aussi une référence
sur le thème de la condamnation de la guerre.
Comme d’autres grands écrivains de l’époque
(je pense notamment à Stefan Zweig), Céline
défend l’idée que la guerre c’est simplement,
en dernière instance, les élites qui envoient
le peuple à l’abattoir.
Sur la forme, comme je l’ai dit, ce roman
renouvelle le style littéraire. Il montre
que la langue parlée est une riche source
de créativité pour importer de nouvelles
images et de nouveaux rythmes dans la langue
écrite.
Le style de Céline fascinera et influencera
beaucoup d’auteurs ultérieurs. Il les désinhibera,
il leur donnera le courage d’être originaux
(même si, bien sûr, beaucoup se contenteront
d’écrire « à la manière de Céline »). Il
inspirera certains à libérer bien plus radicalement
la langue écrite à partir de la langue parlée,
à l’image de Jack Kerouac, le célèbre
auteur de Sur la route (le roman qui annonce
la révolution culturelle des années 1960).
En revanche, le message de Voyage au bout
de la nuit a un peu été oublié par la postérité.
C’est certainement parce que les pamphlets
antisémites écrits par Céline dans les
années 1930 lui ont fait perdre tout crédit
intellectuel (certains lui refusent carrément
sa place dans la littérature française à
cause de ces livres).
Mais tout de même, en 1999, une consultation
populaire française classe Voyage au bout
de la nuit à la 6ème place des 100 meilleurs
livres du XXe siècle.
________________
SEIZIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
La Nausée (1938), Sartre
Lorsque ce roman sort en 1938, il produit
dans le monde littéraire un effet comparable
à celui du Voyage au bout de la nuit de Céline.
On parle de Sartre pour le prix Goncourt.
Ce succès est la récompense d’un long
effort : cela fait huit ans que Sartre a commencé
à écrire ce roman. Les éditions Gallimard
ont même pris 12 mois pour réviser le manuscrit.
Sur les conseils d’un avocat, elles ont
fait pression sur Sartre pour qu’il supprime
les passages trop crus (ce qui représentait
pas mal de pages). Mais Sartre peut dire merci
à son éditeur, parce que c’est Gaston
Gallimard lui-même qui trouve le titre La
Nausée.
Le mot « nausée », qui vient du grec nausia,
« mal de mer », qui désigne une envie de
vomir — et par extension un dégoût violent.
Que retenir de la forme ?
Le roman est écrit à la première personne.
Antoine Roquentin raconte son histoire de
manière introspective, en évoquant ses crises
métaphysiques. Étant donné que Sartre est
philosophe de formation, son style est plutôt
sec, presque professoral (parmi ceux qui n’aiment
pas La nausée, certains disent que c’est
une dissertation déguisée en roman). Après,
Sartre crée quand même des images pour décrire
l’état émotionnel du protagoniste. Il
fait aussi ressentir le malaise du personnage
en répétant le mot « nausée ». Enfin,
il est bien romancier quand il décrit les
lieux et les personnages dans le détail.
Son style est globalement accessible. Sartre
combine des phrases courtes et des phrases
longues, ce qui crée du dynamisme. Sur le
plan du vocabulaire, il sait faire simple
et juste. Sa prose se complexifie — en particulier
la structure de la phrase — lorsqu’il
décrit les pensées du protagoniste. Cela
correspond certes à l’esprit torturé d’Antoine
Roquentin, mais c’est un style lourd pour
le lecteur.
Que retenir du fond, maintenant ?
Antoine Roquentin — qui est un peu l’alter
ego de Sartre — est un historien d’une
trentaine d’années. Il vit seul à Bouville,
une ville imaginaire qui rappelle Le Havre,
où Sartre a été prof de philo de 26 ans
à 31 ans. Attiré par l’aventure et l’exotisme,
il avait voyagé ; puis il avait travaillé
en Indochine. Mais lassé, il vit désormais
de ses rentes, ce qui lui permet de travailler
à la biographie d’un aristocrate de la
fin du XVIIIe siècle.
Le texte du roman est celui du journal intime
d’Antoine Roquentin, dans lequel il décrit
son évolution psychologique. Il sent la nausée
monter en lui. Les objets quotidiens créent
en lui une impression désagréable — puis
cette impression s’étend à tout. Roquentin
se rend compte du vide de sa propre existence
et du dégoût qu’il en ressent.
Ce vide existentiel le détache de tout, y
compris des relations humaines. Sa rencontre
et ses échanges avec un autodidacte à la
bibliothèque ne dissipent pas sa nausée.
Comme Sartre, Roquentin ne supporte pas la
bourgeoisie provinciale. Il se désintéresse
du personnage de l’aristocrate sur lequel
il veut écrire, donc il abandonne son projet
de livre. Alors il se replie sur lui-même.
Il prend conscience, par une introspection
philosophique, du vertige radical de son existence.
Il revoit son ex-compagne Anny et apprend
qu’elle va partir pour Londres, le laissant,
lui, dans une solitude absolue, sans aucune
attache avec l’humanité. Mais peut-être
sortira-t-il de la nausée et se réconciliera-t-il
avec la vie en écrivant un roman.
La Nausée est la référence du courant existentialiste
en littérature, comme la conférence L’existentialisme
est un humanisme l’est en philosophie.
Pour rappel, l’existentialisme est le mouvement
philosophique du XXe siècle qui affirme la
vocation de l’homme à définir lui-même
par ses actes ce qu’il entend être. C’est
dans ce sens que Sartre dira que « l’existence
précède l’essence ».
À travers le personnage d’Antoine Roquentin,
La Nausée met en scène et analyse le malaise
existentiel qui accompagne la prise de conscience
individuelle du fait que le monde et l’existence
sont dépourvus de sens, que l’homme est
condamné à être radicalement libre (ce
que Sartre appelle la « contingence », soit
l’absence de déterminisme). C’est de
cette prise de conscience que découle la
morale existentialiste, selon laquelle l'homme
doit se réaliser dans l'action, notamment
dans l'engagement pour la libération sociale.
Ce roman sera un pilier de l’existentialisme,
qui deviendra un mouvement culturel majeur
au cours des Trente Glorieuses. Il est aussi
un exemple célèbre de l’effet psychologique
de la lecture. L’atmosphère d’un roman
peut contaminer l’état émotionnel du lecteur.
Comme beaucoup de gens, je me suis senti mal
à l’aise en lisant La Nausée. Certains
vont jusqu’à déconseiller ce roman aux
personnes dépressives — et je suis un peu
d’accord !
________________
DIX-SEPTIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
L'Étranger (1942), Albert Camus
Devenue première dame de France en épousant
le président Nicolas Sarkozy en 2008, la
mannequin et chanteuse Carla Bruni a donc
été amené à rencontrer les dirigeants
de la planète lors de voyages diplomatiques.
Elle a par exemple raconté son échange avec
George Bush Junior, le président américain
de l’époque. Ils ont parlé d’Albert
Camus, et… Bush lui a révélé que L’Étranger
était son livre préféré !
Il s’agit d’un petit roman (moins de 200
pages) qui se lit facilement.
On retrouve la simplicité et la concision
qui sont la marque de fabrique du style d’Albert
Camus (qui est un des meilleurs exemples du
fait qu’il n’est pas nécessaire d’écrire
des phrases compliquées pour être un grand
écrivain). Camus se sert de phrases courtes
et directes pour décrire les événements
et les pensées du personnage principal. Il
évite les longues descriptions et les analyses
psychologiques complexes — il préfère
laisser les événements et les actions parler
d'eux-mêmes.
Le célèbre incipit (les deux premières
phrases) du roman en est un exemple éloquent
: « Aujourd’hui, maman est morte. Ou peut-être
hier, je ne sais pas ». C’est très court,
et pourtant ça en dit long sur la psychologie
du personnage (dont on comprend immédiatement
qu’elle n’est pas celle de l’homme ordinaire).
Camus adapte également son style au contenu
du roman. Il émane un grand détachement
de ses choix de mots, qui reflètent l’attitude
distante et stoïque du protagoniste.
Maintenant, je vous résume l’intrigue.
Le personnage-narrateur, Meursault, vit à
Alger, à l’époque de Algérie française.
Apprenant la mort de sa mère, il se déplace
pour la veillée et les funérailles. Il semble
étonnament peu affecté par la disparition.
En fait, il n’est pas triste, et il n’est
pas prêt à faire semblant.
Des événements décisifs surviennent dans
les jours suivant l'enterrement. Meursault
retrouve une femme qui avait travaillé dans
la même entreprise que lui, Marie, et ils
entament une relation. Son voisin Raymond,
un proxénète notoire, l’implique dans
ses problèmes de couple — il maltraite
sa maîtresse et craint les représailles
de ses frères. Meursault témoignera en sa
faveur lorsque la police convoquera Raymond
au commissariat. Dans les jours suivants,
Meursault accepte la demande en mariage de
Marie en précisant que cela n’a pas d’importance
à ses yeux.
C’est alors que se produit l’événement
déterminant dans son destin. Lors d’une
promenade, Raymond, un ami et Meursault — tous
trois sous l’effet conjoint, peu favorable
à la lucidité, de l’alcool et de la chaleur
— ils croisent le frère de la maîtresse
battue par Raymond, et une bagarre éclate.
Par précaution, Meursault avait demandé
à Raymond de lui confier son revolver pour
éviter un drame. Mais lorsque, seul cette
fois-ci, Meursault rencontre à nouveau un
des hommes qui s’est battu avec Raymond
plus tôt, et que cet homme sort un couteau
— alors Meursault sort le revolver et tue
d’une seule balle l’homme qui le menace.
Puis, de manière inexplicable, il tire quatre
autres coups sur le corps inerte.
Commence alors la seconde partie du roman,
dans laquelle le processus judiciaire met
en lumière l’étrangeté de Meursault.
Son absence de regrets et son ennui de l’existence
mettent son avocat mal à l’aise. Son attitude
et son état émotionnel ne changent pas lors
du procès. Son explication maladroite — il
explique son acte par une hallucination causée
par le soleil — le fait passer pour un sociopathe.
Il est condamné à mort. Dans ses derniers
instants, il refuse le secours de la religion,
préférant se préparer seul à la mort.
Albert Camus refusait l’étiquette « existentialiste
», mais il passe dans la littérature française
pour l’autre grand romancier existentialiste
après Sartre. Meursault et Roquentin (le
protagoniste de La Nausée de Sartre) partagent
l’indifférence aux désirs et aux normes
de la société, mais leur psychologie n’est
pas exactement la même : le personnage de
Camus vit dans l’absurde et l’incompréhension,
celui de Sartre dans le dégoût.
Sur le plan de la forme, L’Étranger marque
la littérature française par la puissance
de la simplicité du style de Camus. Cette
simplicité contraste avec les analyses psychologiques
complexes qui étaient courantes à l’époque
comme avec les longues descriptions qui alourdissent
les romans des siècles précédents. Le style
de Camus est emblématique de la simplification
de la prose anticipée par Jack London (notamment)
au tournant du XXe siècle. C’est aussi
un retour aux valeurs du style classique,
la clarté et la concision.
Sur le plan plus général de la culture,
l’influence de L’Étranger est à replacer
dans le grand mouvement d’affaiblissement
de la tradition au XXe siècle. Comme La Nausée,
il a joué un rôle dans l'élargissement
des horizons littéraires et philosophiques
de l’époque.
________________
DIX-HUITIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
Le Petit Prince (1943), Antoine de Saint-Exupéry
Traduit dans plus de 300 langues, ce livre
serait le plus lu au monde… après La Bible
!
Une des raisons, c’est qu’il n’est pas
difficile à lire. Il ne fait qu’une centaine
de pages, et Antoine de Saint-Exupéry écrit
avec une langue simple et accessible (Le Petit
Prince passe avant tout pour un conte pour
enfant). Le style est très poétique, mais
sans être compliqué. La plupart des phrases
sont courtes, ce qui permet de transmettre
des idées claires tout en faisant avancer
l’histoire à un rythme soutenu. Les phrases
tendent néanmoins à s’allonger lorsque
Saint-Exupéry explore des thèmes plus profonds.
80 ans après la parution du livre, la simplicité
poétique de son style plaît toujours autant
aux lecteurs, adultes comme enfants. Ils sont
toujours impressionnés par la capacité de
Saint-Exupéry à évoquer des idées philosophiques
de manière métaphorique.
Je vous résume rapidement l’histoire.
Le narrateur est un aviateur en panne de moteur
dans le désert du Sahara. Il y rencontre
le personnage du Petit Prince, qui lui demande
de dessiner un mouton. Ils apprennent à se
connaître. Le Petit Prince raconte qu’il
vient d’une planète à peine plus grande
qu’une maison, et qu’il a laissé derrière
lui trois volcans et une rose unique dont
il est amoureux.
Il a aussi visité d’autres planètes avant
d’arriver sur Terre. Il y a rencontré des
individus bizarres (qui sont des archétypes),
comme un roi qui prétend tout gouverner,
un vaniteux qui se prend pour l’homme le
plus beau et le plus intelligent alors qu’il
est seul sur sa minuscule planète, un homme
d’affaires qui passe son temps à compter
les étoiles dont il est propriétaire, ou
encore un ivrogne. Sur Terre, le Petit Prince
a notamment rencontré un renard qui lui a
délivré une leçon importante sur la valeur
de l’amitié.
L’aviateur en apprend davantage sur son
petit ami chaque jour, jusqu’à leur séparation
le huitième jour. Le Petit Prince retourne
sur sa planète. Le narrateur, quant à lui,
peut quitter le désert après avoir réparé
son avion. Il part en espérant revoir le
Petit Prince un jour.
L’importance du Petit Prince dans la littérature
se résume au fait qu’il est probablement
la plus puissante allégorie sur la laideur
du monde des hommes. Au départ considéré
comme un conte pour enfants, il est devenu
un conte philosophique pour les adultes. La
figure du Petit Prince sert à mettre en accusation
le monde des adultes, où il n’est plus
possible de goûter la beauté de la vie avec
la pureté de l’enfance.
Si ce roman a si bien marché, c’est parce
qu’il permet à tout un chacun de méditer
des thèmes universels (la solitude, l’amitié,
l’amour, le sens de la vie) à partir d’images
aussi puissantes que simples. Lire Le Petit
Prince est une expérience à la fois émotionnelle
et philosophique, spirituelle, voire initiatique.
Le lecteur ressort transformé.
La figure du Petit Prince s’est imprimée
dans l’imaginaire collectif (surtout occidental).
Elle y symbolise le point de vue de l’innocence,
de la pureté dans un monde compliqué et
sombre, où la pureté est introuvable (surtout
à l’époque de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
au cours de laquelle écrit Saint-Exupéry).
Ses aquarelles d’une simplicité enfantine
ont également contribué à populariser le
personnage du Petit Prince. L’histoire a
été diffusée au-delà de la littérature
grâce à de nombreuses adaptations cinématographiques,
musicales et théâtrales.
Saint-Exupéry et son Petit Prince sont devenus
une référence incontournable de la culture
française, au point qu’ils illustrent le
billet de 50 francs en 1992.
________________
DIX-NEUVIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
La Gloire de mon père (1957), Marcel Pagnol
Au cours d’une discussion avec la femme
d’un ami qui travaille pour le magazine
de mode Elle, Marcel Pagnol promet d’écrire
sur son enfance. Mais comme il se consacre
au cinéma et au théâtre, ce projet littéraire
n’est pas sa priorité — seulement, sa
promesse n’est pas tombée dans l’oreille
d’une sourde. La femme de son ami lui rappelle
son engagement, et c’est grâce à cette
pression sociale qu’un des romans les plus
emblématiques de la culture française — un
roman autobiographique — voit le jour.
Que dire de La Gloire de mon père sur la
forme ?
Pagnol raconte l’histoire de son enfance
à la première personne, ce qui donne un
côté intime à la narration. Autrement dit,
le lecteur se relie plus facilement au personnage
principal, dont il partage les expériences
et les émotions. Le style de Pagnol facilite
également l’immersion dans l’histoire
: il décrit efficacement les personnages,
les situations et les paysages ; les expressions
et les mots provençaux donnent de l’authenticité
et de la couleur au récit ; l’humour des
dialogues rend la lecture agréable.
Le style de Pagnol est globalement simple
et vivant. Ses phrases directes, plutôt courtes
ou moyennes, conservent l’attention du lecteur
le long de l’histoire. Son langage accessible
crée une atmosphère conviviale et chaleureuse.
Le talent littéraire de Pagnol réside dans
sa capacité de rendre l’histoire savoureuse
et dans la peinture des caractères (c’est-à-dire
la psychologie des personnages).
Que retenir de l’histoire, maintenant ?
Marcel Pagnol raconte sa naissance et ses
origines familiales. Il raconte également
les promenades au parc avec sa tante Rose
lorsqu’il a six ans, qui sont un prétexte
pour passer du temps avec l’homme dont elle
est éprise (qui deviendra l’oncle Jules).
Une dimension importante des souvenirs de
Pagnol est la naissance de son attachement
pour la Provence, qui survient lorsque sa
famille et celle de sa tante partagent une
maison de campagne pour les vacances d’été
de 1904. Le jeune Marcel et son frère tombent
amoureux de l’environnement emblématique
de la Provence, les collines, les roches et
la végétation.
Un événement donne son titre au roman. Marcel
suit en secret son père et son oncle partis
à la chasse. Il les perd, puis les retrouve
grâce aux sons des coups de fusil. Il est
témoin d’un petit exploit de son père
: il a réussi à abattre une paire de perdrix
en plein vol en un seul tir, ce qui fait « la
gloire de son père » dans le village. Mais
dans un accès de vanité, son père accepte
de se faire prendre en photo avec les oiseaux,
alors que lui-même s’était moqué d’un
collègue qui avait fait la même chose avec
un poisson. Cette faiblesse dissout l’image
idéale que Marcel a de son père, mais renforce
son amour filial.
La Gloire de mon père a marqué la littérature
française pour deux raisons.
Tout d’abord, il est devenu l’œuvre emblématique
des souvenirs d’enfance. L’école primaire,
le cocon familial, les vacances dans les collines
provencales, ou encore la chasse avec le père
ne sont certes pas le lot de tous les enfants,
mais ces ingrédients symbolisent dans l’imaginaire
collectif une enfance épanouie. Cet épanouissement
tient en bonne partie aux personnages, humains,
mais aimants et attachants, que décrit Pagnol.
Avec le succès fulgurant du livre, le père
instituteur, la mère timide, l’oncle, la
tante, et le petit frère sont devenus des
figures très populaires.
La seconde raison pour laquelle La Gloire
de mon père a marqué la littérature française
est la mise en valeur de la Provence (la région
de Marseille). Le roman donne une image idyllique
de la région : la nature est magnifique ; les
villages charmants ; les habitants chaleureux
; et leurs coutumes agréables.
La portée culturelle de ce livre dépasse
la seule littérature. Il a nourri deux archétypes
: celui de l’enfance épanouie dans une
famille harmonieuse, en particulier dans la
relation au père (à opposer à l’idée
freudienne, prégnante à l’époque, de
l’enfance et du complexe d'Oedipe comme
sources de névroses) ; et puis l’archétype
de la Provence comme région idyllique. L’adaptation
au cinéma a renforcé ces archétypes (notamment
celui de la Provence, dont les images permettent
d’admirer les paysages).
________________
VINGTIÈME RÉFÉRENCE
La Promesse de l'aube (1960), Romain Gary
C’est le rapport de Romain Gary à la vérité
qui autorise à classer ce livre parmi les
romans. Le récit est certes très autobiographique,
mais l’auteur multiplie les entorses avérées
à la réalité factuelle. Il aime mystifier
les lecteurs, la presse et l’opinion publique.
Il écrit certains romans sous son vrai nom,
d’autres sous le pseudonyme d’Émile Ajar
— et il fait tenir le rôle public de cet
écrivain à son petit-cousin ! La tromperie
réussit si bien que Gary décroche deux fois
le prix Goncourt, ce que les règles du concours
interdisent.
Sur la forme, le livre est accessible.
Le style exprime une grande sensibilité de
manière relativement simple. Gary décrit
les relations humaines — tout particulièrement
celle qu’il entretient avec sa mère — avec
des images fines et puissantes. Son art de
la métaphore transparaît lorsqu’il donne
vie à ses souvenirs. Enfin, il manie l’autodérision,
ce qui le rapproche du lecteur. Au total,
la prose de Gary est fluide, avec des phrases
de longueurs variables qui s'adaptent au rythme
du récit. Il rend la narration captivante
en variant les procédés stylistiques (métaphores,
comparaisons saisissantes, jeux de mots, dialogues
enlevés).
Voici maintenant un résumé de l’histoire.
Romain Gary est à la fois l’auteur et le
narrateur.
Sa mère a beaucoup d’ambition pour lui
: elle prédit qu’il deviendra célèbre.
Elle reporte ses espoirs sur lui après avoir
renoncé à sa carrière d’actrice. Elle
lui donne énormément d’amour, mais elle
est envahissante.
Lorsqu’ils vivent dans la Lituanie actuelle,
au début du roman, Romain essaie la peinture,
la musique et la danse — mais il se tourne
finalement vers l’écriture. Comme Hitler
arrive au pouvoir, ils vont s’installer
à Nice, parce que la mère de Romain adore
la France. Les débuts de leur vie d’immigrés
sont difficiles, jusqu’à ce qu’elle devienne
gérante d’un hôtel.
Ils se séparent lorsque Romain part faire
une licence de droit à Paris, mais la mère
continue de suivre le destin de son fils et
de l’alimenter de sa foi. Lui, de son côté,
ne veut pas la décevoir. Lorsqu’une promotion
militaire lui est refusée parce qu’il n’est
pas français depuis assez longtemps, il ment
à sa mère en lui disant qu’il paie en
réalité ses frasques de séducteur (il aurait
couché avec la femme du chef).
Ensuite, elle lui écrit de nombreuses lettres
lorsqu’il combat lors de la Deuxième Guerre
mondiale. Résistant, il est promu capitaine
à la fin du conflit. Seulement, il ne peut
pas goûter la fierté de sa mère : il apprend
à son retour en France qu’elle est morte
depuis plusieurs années. Il devient écrivain,
comme sa mère l’avait prédit, mais elle
n’est plus là pour le voir réaliser l’ambition
qu’elle avait placée en lui.
Pour faire simple, ce roman est, dans la littérature
française, la référence sur le thème de
l’amour maternelle (et plus précisément
de la relation mère-fils). L’hommage que
Romain Gary rend à sa mère est une réflexion
profonde sur le rapport à l’existence qu’engendre
l’amour inconditionnelle d’une mère.
C’est le sens du titre, qui est tirée d’une
phrase du livre : « Avec l’amour maternel,
la vie vous fait, à l’aube, une promesse
qu’elle ne tient jamais ». Mais la promesse
est double. D’un côté, la vie fait au
fils une promesse d’amour inconditionnel
— mais cet amour disparaîtra avec la mère,
et le fils devra poursuivre son existence
seul, rendu dépressif par l’attente irréaliste
d’un amour comparable à celui de la source
maternelle ; l’autre côté de la promesse
de l’aube, c’est le fils qui promet à
sa mère d’accomplir ses vœux de succès.
« Si ma mère avait eu un amant, je n'aurais
pas passé ma vie à mourir de soif auprès
de chaque fontaine », écrit joliment Romain
Gary.
Le style est très bon, et Romain Gary contribue
à renouveler le récit autobiographique par
son subtil mélange de la réalité et de
la fiction — mais c’est le sujet du roman
qui a touché le cœur de tant de lecteurs.
C’est une démonstration magnifique du fait
que l’amour maternel peut être à la fois
une bénéfiction et une malédiction.
________________
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.